>> All right. So we should take a moment to define
inductive learning. So inductive learning is
learning from examples. It's the kind
of learning problem that we've been looking at the whole time, But
we haven't been very precise about all the various quantities that we
want to be able to talk about. So the number of properties
that we actually need to be thinking about when we go and
define what an inductive learning problem is, and measure what an inductive
learning algorithm does. So one of them is just a simple thing
like, what's the probability that the training is actually is going
work. You know, whatever it is that it's trying to produce,
it may be that in some cases, because the data is
really noisy or just you know, got a, got a bad set
of data, it might not actually work. So, we generally talk
about a quantity like 1 minus delta as the probability of success.
Delta here obviously is a probability of failure and this is
just 1 minus that. There's also issues like the number of examples
to train on. How many, how much data does the does the algorithm
get to see? . Is there a letter you like for that, Charles?
>> no.
>> Okay.
>> Is there a letter you like?
>> I don't know, sometimes I like M for number of samples. But I thought
maybe you went, you would want N because, you know, things tend to grow with N.
>> Yeah. I did want N, but then I thought well,
we can't use N because we use N for everything else.
>> [LAUGH] Fair enough. There's also something that we really
haven't talked about yet, but you could imagine that the complexity
of the hypothesis class might matter. Why, why
do you think that could come into play, Charles?
>> Well, if you don't have a very
complex hypothesis class, then there's some things, well,
do you mean the complexity of the class
or the complexity of the hypotheses in the class?
>> That's a good question. Do we mean the complexity of the
class or the complexity of the hypotheses in the class? Well it
depends on how we measure complexity. But the complexity of the class
could be like the sum of the complexities of all the hypotheses
in the class, so it could be both.
>> Hm. Well if, if you mean, you know, a hypothesis class is complex if
it has very complex hypotheses, then you can say, well, if you have a hypothesis
class that can't represent much, then it
will be hard for you to, well, represent
much. It will be hard for you
to learn anything complicated. So that could matter.
>> Sure. That's right. Now, could you see a downside to having
a complexity class, I'm sorry, a hypothesis class that is very, very
complex?
>> You mean like my daughter? sure. I think
you could, it would be much easier to overfit.
>> Right. So getting something that actually works well might
be challenging. You might need a lot more data to
kind of nail down what your're, what you're really talking
about. So it's a bit of a double edged sword.
All right. So then, there, another issue is, well, you
know, it may be easy to learn if you don't
have to learn very well. [LAUGH] So the, the accuracy
to which the target concept is approximated, often written as epsilon,
is another thing that's going to be important in understanding
the complexity of a learning algorithm. And and so those, those
are kind of the main complexity related quantities that I,
that I wanted to talk about. But there's also some choices
as to how the learning problem is actually framed. There's
the manner in which training examples are presented. And there's the
manner in which training examples are selected for presentation. And we're
going to talk about both of these. Let me just first
say that when I talk about the
manner in which training examples are presented, there's,
there's two that I think are really, really important to look at. One is batch
and that's mostly what we've looked at
so far, that there's a training set that's
fixed and handed over to the algorithm in a big bolus, right. A big group.
>> A big batch.
>> A big batch, exactly. Or it could also be presented on line, so
one at a time. So we say to the training algorithm, or the learning algorithm,
here's an example. And then it has to predict what
the label is. And then the algorithm can say, oh
here's what the right label is. Let's try again. Here's
another example. And it can go back and forth like that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We haven't really talked about algorithms that work that way, but
it is useful in the context of computational learning theory to have
both kinds of algorithms. They have different sorts of behavior. All right.
So let's talk about the manner in which training examples are selected.